hallo mein name ist so kann ehrlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video youtube macht irgendwie videos
über ihren tollen sportwagen derart viel
geld kostet deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
da unglaublich viele fragen aufkamen
[Musik]
weil es ein so oft gewünscht habe ich
mir gedacht ich stelle euch heute
einfach mal mein auto vor der stelle
muss ich allerdings sagen ich bin nicht
wirklich für alles dankbar
also ich liebe euch über alles ich kann
nicht oft genug sagen wie dankbar ich
bin ohne euch wäre das alles nicht
möglich gewesen
[Musik]
hier wurde
da vorne das ist der brandneue porsche
911 carrera 370 millionen newtonmeter
alles von null auf 100 in 4 sekunden
fühlt sich aber an die eine sekunde weil
er halt echt krass sieht guckt ihr mann
die endrohre an die empore sind nämlich
in der mitte und hat man die nur außen
deswegen ist es ein bisschen was
besonderes hier schönheit logo 9 11 an
hier sehen wir die schönen
pirelli-reifen die schönen 20 zoll
felgen hier vorne haben natürlich auch
reifen
wir haben hier schöne szene und
scheinwerfer wir haben hier mit einem
knopfdruck geht der kofferraum
aschenhausen hier nachhelfen ist der
kofferraum auch schon offen
das ganze haus dann auch von innen aus
man kann sich hier natürlich auch
einsetzt man muss das auto jetzt nicht
im stehen
das ist die karl huber spitzen feature
so sieht das ganze hier von innen heraus
wir haben hier sehr schöne neue
vorschläge hat mit den tollen nähten
hier damit alles toll ist wir haben wir
verschiedene knöpfchen wie
beispielsweise die auspuff mit start
stopp automatik oder ausfahren sport
modus sport plus modus den ist ein
automatik also muss ich muss nicht
schalten wir haben das navi wir haben
verschiedene andere knöpfchen ich habe
hier auch von dass das ist ich hab ihr
lied trinker alternde mensch ist das
eine technik du ich werde nicht mehr wie
das ganze auto auf jeden fall von innen
aus ich kann hier auch in den sitz nach
vorne machen dann ist er freilich kann
auch nach hinten machen da ist ja wieder
hinten das war es dann auch schon meine
damen und herren das ist mein auto ich
wollte jetzt einfach mal zeigen
nein spaß ich habe das auto von porsche
bekommen für eine woche lang testweise
weil ich eingeladen wurde zum
hockenheimring von denen und zu dem
rennen da habe ich auch ein paar sachen
gefilmt die blende ich euch jetzt mal
hier ein
[Musik]
nein
während in der boxengasse
die daran alle boxer sind und das ist
eine gasse hat fast die kopf gestoßen
[Musik]
gleich kommen die autos an die gewinner
zu recht ist
außerdem ist
ich hoffe sterben
[Musik]
geblieben
familienkutsche da hinten sitzen dann
alle jäger oder super viel platz für
koffer ist hier noch ein besseres morgen
ist mein auto mein neues zum glück sind
ja auch nicht viele lkws wir alle
sonderreihe stehen lkws
bisher 15 kilometer
dem ich viel wir werden die
besichtigungstermine sowohl die ex als
auch der super cars i got dann wird es
die qualifikation
denn das war es jetzt beim video meine
damen und herren ich würde mir glaube
ich ein auto kaufen weil er einfach bei
meiner fahrweise 16 17 liter verbrauchen
als ein bisschen zu viel das war es
jetzt auf jeden fall ich bedanke mich
bei porsche dass ich das auto fahren
dürfen durfte für einen eineinhalb
wochen
dass überhaupt ein ring war ultra coole
findet alle möglichen personen leute die
ich da getroffen habe in der
beschreibung übrigens auch dank an um
mit kurzfilmen bin nicht mal selbst
geben damit sie sehen wer du bist
auf jeden fall
das sollte so ein bisschen power designs